Freunde herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen Folge ein Tag persönlicher Koch
heute mal aus dem Sitzen die
Anmoderation und der ein oder andere
erkennt vielleicht den Hintergrund ich
bin hier bei den einzig wahren Eli freut
mich sehr dass ich hier bei dir am Start
sein darf ja heute koche ich für dich
drei Gerichte du bist leider bisschen
lädiert deshalb würde ich sagen gehe ich
mal in die Küche und habe hier eine
schöne Smoothie bauen aber ich freue
mich auch hier bei der Informat dabei zu
sein weil ich gucke mir wirklich beim
Essen fast alle deine Videos an ne auch
diese ganzen
verschiedenen Städten auch kennengelernt
ich habe dir nämlich geschrieben du
solltest in Berlin machen weil in Berlin
habe ich schon alles durch und irgendwie
brauche ich eine leben wo ich dich
gleich wenn es nur fertig ist und wir
machen uns an die Arbeit kommen jetzt
zum Frühstück wie gesagt eine Smoothie
Ball Zeichen ein paar Sachen aus schön
gesund deshalb arbeiten wir auch mit ein
paar superfoods wir haben hier so ein
bisschen Leinsamen dabei wir haben
Spirulina aber ich wollte schon immer
mal so eine knallig blaue Bowl machen
heute ist es endlich soweit dieses Zeug
ist unglaublich schwer zu bekommen aber
wir haben es geschafft also ganz einfach
ihr kennt es mittlerweile wenn irgendwas
wurde mit gefrorenen Zutaten arbeitest
erstmal was flüssiges rein ich nehme
jetzt ein bisschen kokosjoghurt einfach
um die Klinge zu schützen wir wollen so
eine richtig schöne dickflüssige baul
haben weil ich finde das macht so eine
richtig geile Bowl aus vielleicht
schaffen wir es auch dass ich das hier
so geil dreht im Mixer weil das ist
immer das was ich liebe so dann
hinterher gefrorene Mango und gefrorene
Banane ohne Banane kann man so übrigens
nicht im Supermarkt kaufen wollt jetzt
beten und den Mixer anschalten unser
nächster hier rüber kaputt gegangen
hatte hauen wir das Ding mal an
am besten nicht in Holzlöffel
reinstecken und wenn sich das Ganze
dreht geben wir eine kleine Löffelspitze
Spirulina hinein ist inspirieren noch
drauf
die perfekte Konsistenz haben sie dieses
leicht gefrorene so gebe ich das ganze
nochmal für 10 Minuten in den
Gefrierschrank Freunde wir probiert die
Konsistenz mal ein bisschen zu sehen es
ist immer noch relativ flüssig wir
kriegen nicht dieses perfekt
dickflüssige hin ich glaube der Mixer
war nicht stark genug und sind die
Sachen sind ein bisschen angetaut wegen
dem Transport aber ey das ist meckern
auf hohem Niveau die Farbe ist richtig
schön aus ist gar nicht so viel wie
gedacht ja Leute ich bin nicht 100%
zufrieden mit der Konsistenz sage ich
ganz ehrlich aber vielleicht hat Eli
auch noch nie eine Smoothie Burger
gegessen und kannst dich vorbereiten
jetzt stylen wir das ganze wird in einer
Linie jetzt hier quasi die Blaubeeren
platzieren es soll wirklich so ein Ding
sein so wenn man das ist dann fühlt man
sich so 10 von 10 gesund
mal wieder hinter der Kamera deshalb
kein lautes Lachen im Hintergrund
mit dem Geodreieck wird das hier
angerichtet Kompass guter Letzt noch ein
bisschen Granola drüber und fertig ist
unsere wunderhübsche smootball ein
bisschen flüssig geworden ist nicht
wundern wir werden jetzt gleich im
Stream den test test machen und ich
verwende das Material von Eli deshalb
seht jetzt wie ich da reinkomme
nach Hause geholt das ist aber wirklich
voll gut aus wir haben hier eine
Smoothie Ball die Basis ist kokosjoghurt
dazu haben wir gefrorene Mango gefrorene
Banane mit Spirulina also quasi blauer
Alge das ist so ein super food oben
drauf Topping Blaubeeren Leinsamen Kokos
Chips und Granola und das ist aber das
ist gesund das ist gesünder als alles
was wir heute noch essen werden sage ich
mal auf jeden Fall haben
ich freue mich auf die ehrliche Meinung
auf jeden Fall ich glaube du wirst das
hart und fair bewerten also ich war
richtig gut ja wie so ein geiler Joghurt
schmeckt wirklich sehr gut ja das Ding
in so einem fancy Restaurant ja
14,90 € in Berlin einen guten Spot
[Musik]
ja ja
wirklich lecker
richtig eine gute Art let's go aber es
schmeckt ultra gut also schmeckt super
weißt du ich würde sagen nach 8 1/2 8
1/2 schmeckt wirklich sehr lecker
Maschine geil freut mich sehr das ist
ein sehr guter Start in den Tag ich
glaube wir machen mit dem Mittagessen
weiter Freunde wir sind gerade live im
Stream hier hinten wird gefilmt und wir
machen jetzt für die cheese Deck die
gefüllt werden mit Haupt drin
geschnitten die einfach ganz simpel
gesalzen gefällt sind angebraten sind
dazu ein paar gegrillte Zwiebel ein
bisschen gegrillte grüne Paprika ganze
taucht man dann mit cheese deshalb
cheese Steak Sandwich und an für sich
eine super simple Sache abonniert diesen
Kanal ich sitze immer hier mitten in der
Nacht nach dem Stream und guck mir deine
ganzen Essen man seit zwei drei Jahren
bin ich da ne also ich kenne ich danke
dir ich habe ja als kleines Danke schon
mal was mitgebracht in meiner eigenen
Produkte guck mal hier einmal für dich
zeitbox mit der du einfach schön alles
entspannt seid kannst
können wir einfach alles unten
reinpacken gibt's da einen Link Block
Punkt Shop ja Mods Haut den Link da rein
hier ist echt cool
Werbung machen in deinem Spiel ich
wollte in meinem Video ja machen
okay ich kann sowas ganz gut verstehen
also ich nehme das Messer und schneide
hier einmal so dünne Streifen von runter
für unser cheese Steak das ist rot dass
das Brot du kannst ja mal fühlen das
sieht schon so richtig aus wie so ein
amerikanisches Hoverboard ist so gerne
scharf ja ja Jalapenos rein ja
da war ich mir nicht sicher ob du denkst
aber Schmelzkäse für mich ein absolutes
Muss aber es gibt Leute die sagen ja das
ist industriekäse oder irgendwas ich
habe auch ein Shadow geholt falls du das
lieber magst aber ich dachte ehrlich wir
sollten den hier nehmen du bist
derjenige ich auch einfach mal den äh
Wissenschaft für sich selber Freunde
kleines Update aus dem Livestream ich
bin hier gerade die grüne Paprika Karten
für unser Polizist hier Ciabatta rolls
drüben Zwiebeln geschnitten und hier
drüben ist schon mal unsere Code ein in
Streifen geschnitten ich finde die Tafel
am Boden ne ja habe ich alles selbst
gemacht tatsächlich nein hat eh gemacht
richtig gut
auf so einer großen Pfanne anpassen aber
die sind einfach zu groß das habe ich
hier jetzt einmal so aufschneide dass
man sie aufklappen kann bisschen
Olivenöl drüber anrösten und dann können
wir das ganze in den Ofen geben ich habe
ordentlich Olivenöl auch die Innenseite
von unserem Charakter gegeben und lege
das ganze jetzt so in den vorgeheizten
Ofen guck mal hier Chat wir haben jetzt
einmal alles schön durchgebraten oh
jetzt einfach erstmal das Steak hier
rein die Steak Pfeifen erstmal komplett
ungewürzt von einer Seite schön anbraten
dass die Farbe bekommt und dann würzen
wir darüber mit Knoblauchpulver Salz mit
Pfeffer das heißt das habe ich gemacht
[Musik]
man kann das schön gar ziehen genau
wichtig dass es nicht ganz durch ist
damit schön saftig bleibt und auch
wichtig dass es noch gut weil ein gutes
Steak egal wo muss ruhen okay sollen wir
zusammenbauen ja Freunde ihr merkt alles
bisschen anders heute ich hoffe ihr
konntet relativ gut nachvollziehen was
wir so gemacht haben ich habe hier auf
jeden Fall jetzt in meinem Ciabatta die
Steak Streifen darauf gebe ich jetzt
einmal hier die gegrillte Paprika mit
den gedrehten Zwiebeln und dann lege ich
darauf so kleine Dreiecke von Sandwich
Käse Haut das ganze noch mal in den Ofen
und dann haben wir einen
Sandwich wie es im Buch steht ich glaube
das wird richtig lecker probieren wir
das ganze jetzt tschüss
Steak ist halt wirklich und schöner
Winter Geschmack Knoblauchpulver finde
ich auch immer super wichtig ist besser
als der normale Käse dieser in
dustrie fertig
[Musik]
gewesen
8 von 10 kann man sich wirklich nicht
Beschwerden ja also sehr gut gemacht
der Höhepunkt kommt heute Abend in Form
von den Lampen komplett mit Eis
Joghurtsoße machen wir uns dann die
Arbeit wir müssen aufwendiger
so Freunde jetzt geht wieder alles ein
bisschen gesitteter zu kommen wir zum
Abendessen es gibt eine wirklich große
Auswahl von Speisen wir haben einmal
Lammkoteletts schön mit Thymian
mariniert dann ziehen wir die später
perfekt im Ofen gar und das wird schon
mal richtig lecker dazu gibt es
orientalischen Reis mit Granatapfel
gerösteten Mandeln und zu guter letzt
noch gebratene Bohnen und ein Joghurt
minzip also alles in allem auf jeden
Fall eine sehr wilde speise ich hoffe
dass wir da vielleicht noch mal die ein
oder andere Note rauskitzeln können aus
aegidien den ein oder anderen extra
Punkt aber es ist einiges zu tun deshalb
fangen wir direkt an hier sind meine
Lampen komplett die ich jetzt einfach
mal großzügig mit Olivenöl übergieße und
ich habe im türkischen Supermarkt so
eine Lamm Marinade gefunden das sind
einfach trocknete Kräuter Thymian
Rosmarin alles mögliche die durch das Öl
wieder mit Feuchtigkeit versorgt werden
wie ich jetzt mal großzügig an und dann
massiere ich das ganze ein bisschen ein
schaut euch das an Freunde wunderschön
bedeckt gleichmäßig bedeckt so lassen
das jetzt einfach ziehen und Stündchen
und in der Zwischenzeit machen wir mit
unserem Reis weiter es ist alles
bisschen anders heute ich hoffe ihr
könnt das mir verzeihen weil wir sind
nicht mehr in der perfekt
ausgeleuchteten Studio Küche wir machen
ein bisschen Freestyle so wie in den
Anfangstagen von PK das war auch was
schönes Basmatireis gebe ich dir meine
Schüssel hinein und jetzt waschen wir
den 4 5 mal aus bis das Wasser nicht
mehr milchig ist und so lassen wir den
Reis jetzt für eine Stunde einweichen
einfach kaltes Wasser bei
Raumtemperaturen Reis werde ich unter
anderem mit Granatapfel zubereiten ich
lasse jetzt hier einfach mal meinen Topf
mit Wasser volllaufen denn es gibt ein
ziemlich guten Trick wenn man
Granatapfel öffnen will ohne sich
komplett zu versauen dann muss man den
Granatapfel an diesen Kanten quasi
einschneiden und so sieht man das ganze
dann unter Wasser auf Sack es dauert
trotzdem ein bisschen aber das erledigen
wir jetzt mal und dann gucken wir weiter
ich werde jetzt schon mal den Minions
Joghurt zubereiten damit er noch ein
bisschen ziehen kann einfach fein
schneiden dann Hexe ich da ein paar mal
drüber und dann rühre ich die unter
meinen griechischen Joghurt mit 10 %
Fett für die Koteletts hier so ein
starken kernigen Geschmack haben Salz
rein probieren
geil ich versuche noch mehr Minze rein
aber das ist richtig lecker weitere
Vorbereitungen für den Reis ich habe
hier ein paar gehobelte Mandeln die gebe
ich einfach eine Pfanne rein röste die
ein bisschen an das wird wirklich viel
mehr als ein Standard Reis knappe halbe
Dreiviertelstunde später ist jetzt
richtig viel von dem Wasser aufgesogen
in den Reis das überschüssige Wasser
schütte ich einmal ab ganzen auch schon
bereit gekocht zu werden gib mir mal
einen guten Schluck Olivenöl Folgen
unsere Zwiebeln wenn die Zwiebeln schön
glasig sind folgt der Knoblauch den
günstig auch noch ein bisschen mit an
und dann kommt auch schon unser Reis zum
Einsatz Knoblauch und Zwiebeln sind
angedünstet rein mit dem Reis
den Braten
jetzt gebe ich die doppelte Menge Brühe
hinein wie ich am Anfang Reis
hineingegeben habe und so lassen wir
stehen bis es einmal aufkocht wenn unser
Reis aufgekocht ist dann gehe ich runter
mit der Hitze auf die niedrigste Stufe
packen den Deckel drauf und jetzt warten
ungefähr 10 Minuten dann sollte er
fertig sein wenn jetzt so viel für den
Reis gemacht unsere Lampe fühlen sich
langsam benachteiligt deshalb gebe ich
jetzt hier in die Pfanne noch ein
bisschen Olivenöl dann braten wir immer
so vier Stück auf einmal an von beiden
Seiten richtig schön scharf damit wir
ordentliche Röstaromen bekommen dann
geht ein bisschen Thymian Rosmarin dazu
ja rosieren das ganze und dann ziehen
wir sie im Ofen gar natürlich Salz mit
unser Lamm auch ordentlich wenn die
richtig schön Farbe bekommen habt dann
drehen wir das Ganze einmal um das
machen wir was schon immer mal machen
wollte wie arosieren das Ganze auf
Englisch heißt das Bacon jede Menge
Butter rein und die Butter geschmolzen
ist gehen wir sie einmal hier schön über
unsere Landesvergleich drüber wow das
sieht der Geschmack von den Kräutern
schön ein dann gleichmäßig bevor die
Butter dann aber braun wird gehen wir
einmal hier runter und geben alles zum
Gas ziehen in den Ofen hinein schön mit
den Kräutern in der Butter bei 90 Grad
im Backofen
und das gleiche machen wir jetzt mit dem
restlichen Lammkotelett und jetzt Leute
das habe ich noch nie gesehen ne
granatapfelkern
und hast du das mal gegessen
und Freunde das Geheimnis der guten
Küche noch ein bisschen Butter mit rein
[Musik]
bisschen Wasser in die Pfanne hinterher
unsere Bohnen ich will die einfach ein
bisschen Wasser hier schön an dünsten
und etwas Knoblauch noch mit dazu
der Reis ist fertig die lammkotel fertig
dass das fertige Gericht und jetzt gehen
wir rüberzulegen
das ist soweit es ist soweit es ist
angerichtet
Lammkoteletts mit Reis und Bohnen also
ich muss sagen es riecht sehr krass es
riecht sehr sehr lecker
das war voll saftig echt anders ne also
da sind voll viele verschiedene
Geschmäcker durch den Granatapfel dann
die Nüsse schmecken
erstmal alles ein bisschen
von innen schön rosa also auch nicht
durch zu durch oder so
es schmeckt wirklich sehr lecker aber
wieso schmeckt die saftig das ist krass
wirklich sehr lecker der der Reis ist
sehr geil ist was anderes aber ich bin
würde ich sagen eher ein Freund von
diesem klassischen türkischen
diese Mandeln drin Granatapfel
irgendwelche Kräutern aber das ist
wirklich sehr lecker also das ganze Ding
jetzt bin ich gespannt das ganze Ding so
langsam
das beste Essen was ich die letzten
Wochen gegessen habe ich mit dem ganzen
Dinge
88 selbst selfmade und so super geil
geil
der hat hier anderthalb zwei Stunden für
uns gekocht du merkst wenn Leute
irgendwie kochen können du merkst das
Freunde das war's von ein Tag
persönlicher Kopf für Eli wirklich es
hat mir großen Spaß gemacht aber richtig
geil du wolltest das Auto machen sagt
irgendwas
für mich gekocht hat und auch an deinen
Kollegen hinter der Kamera sehr
sympathisch hat die normale alles
aufgeräumt mir sehr viel Spaß gemacht
ich habe lange nicht mehr so gut
gegessen ich hoffe dass das du weiter
erfolgreich hast mit den ganzen Jungs
oder Mädels danke abonniert diesen Kanal
mein Gott das muss sagen okay kurz geht
raus Leute ich danke dir freut das geil
aus ich habe noch nichts gegessen